foreign
Texas the 512 and talk to Katie what's
up Katie
oh no
Katie you there
okay sorry you cut out for a second okay
hey what's happening yeah I got you
what's up
um so
um first of all thank you so much this
is awesome I'm super excited also very
nervous so sorry in advance all right
and first of all thank you I'm very
nervous and excited so same same boat
same team we can do it okay awesome is
this still a thousand degrees in Texas
right now oh my God oh my gosh yeah and
I'm eight months pregnant so no no no my
wife's in Texas right now with my kids
and
she just said it's it's a thousand
degrees yeah what are y'all doing fix
that guys what Fest I don't know eight
months pregnant oh gosh jeez I was like
fun fact guys your shins can sweat
last week at work Rose I don't know that
my shins have ever sweat but well done
I'm sure thank you I'm sure I'm sure
it's possible all right so what's up
what's up you Shin sweater that sounds
like a slur
anyway all right what's up
okay
um so about a year ago
um I cut off relationship with my mom
um
actually a device is two therapists
um at the time
um so
uh
growing up it was a pretty chaotic
um existence my sister has high
functioning autism so but they didn't
know it at the time
um so she was very emotional and needed
a lot of attention
um and just behavior all that and then
my dad avoided being home by being at
work
um
and so it left me at home um pretty much
so I was kind of like the buffer between
my mom and my sister and like any time
my mom was just
pressured about anything it just always
was taken out on me
um and it it so there's just like a lot
of baggage and stuff that went with that
and I was having
really hard time last summer
um and I was actually using better
health so plug for that
um
and um
I ended up on better help I started with
a different therapist and then got over
there um but um they're both like you
know I really think
every time you talk to your mom it just
really it doesn't help anything it hurts
um you have a lot of
damage and baggage there I don't know
how much detail you want to go into the
backstory of it all um I mean I trust uh
I mean the the salicious side of me
wants to know like what'd she say what'd
she do but I don't think that's
important here you've got two
professional licensed therapists telling
you hey you need to draw some pretty
hard boundaries right and yeah I know in
my world telling somebody to not talk to
their mom there's got you don't just
throw that around right so if two
different therapists have told you that
then I trust you I trust you I trust
them I trust everybody that this is
where we are okay okay
um there's just like a lot of
gaslighting and
um like everything was my fault and like
everything would be fine and then just
like and I've heard you talk to other
people about this like if you're at home
and you'd be doing something all of a
sudden just like bombs would go off and
you have no idea why and then you're
just trying to madly fix it um and I'm
assuming that has followed you into your
adult life
you're pregnant now and you got another
are you married
yeah it's married and I have a
five-year-old okay so now she wants to
run that relationship too
well yeah and that's part of why I would
cut so frustrated last summer like and
that's what kind of broke the straw for
me was I was having a conversation with
her and she was like well I was really
worried about your son like I thought he
was going to have a weight problem I'm
like he at no point ever had a weight
problem like I don't know where you're
even getting this and then she'd always
make little comments about my husband
and like
it's just stuff about my life like
anything I could be like we're going to
the grocery store this weekend she's
like are you can he can are you sure you
can handle that so we're here so we're
here now
what happened no
so she I
I cut them because they were very cold
and disconnected and it was not sincere
at all
um but this last time she sent a letter
and it was like I moved to apologize for
my selfishness
um
like I didn't recognize your needs
struggles and difficulties as a child
and then was like I love you which is
the first time she said that in any of
her Communications she still signed it
her first name instead of like Mom or
anything but
my husband's like I think that's the
best apology you're ever gonna get out
of the situation
um which I I agree and it kind of feels
like the ball's in my court now like
either like I need to respond and I I
just don't know if I need to and to me
it was a very passive apology like sorry
you had a hard time over there versus
like sorry I was emotionally abusive
well so so here's like as you're talking
here's the thoughts running through my
mind okay and it's gonna sound like I'm
coming at you I'm not I'm leaning up
against your boundaries too okay okay
um
if you cut her off
to try to get something from her that's
manipulation
that's what it feels like
if you cut her off to protect you and
your family and you really didn't even
have a
unless she does a B or C or D and maybe
you explain that to her
um
that's a totally different story but if
you cut her off and then she's just been
like throwing
um little notes over your giant brick
wall and she's trying to figure out what
note is going to open the door
um then that's that's manipulation
that's that's I mean it's almost like
I'm getting you back Mom and I'm Gonna
Get You Back by taking away your
grandkids and your daughter
totally fair
um
I had no intention of trying like I
don't I didn't expect anything out of
her I've actually honestly I think
you've posted this on social media like
pray for they that they have deep
laughter and a great life and like
become whole and heal and I honestly
like I want that for her
I just can't keep putting myself
out of obligation every week because
like I'll be in trouble quote unquote
which I know sounds ridiculous no it
doesn't I mean it's yes it happens but
so so what what is making you feel like
you have to respond to this
um
when I cut
her Beach like in your jaw and
everything hurts um it was like one of
those moments and I sent an email it
wasn't like the most tactful probably
um and I didn't list any grievances so
it's I don't know if it's fair to be
like why aren't you apologizing for the
things I expected you to apologize for
when you don't know what they are
but I I don't know I want to do the
right seeing every you know cutting off
your mom is just such a
huge thing and ever no one understands
it they're like but that's your mom so
it just
I don't I don't want to be cruel I don't
want to
be trying to inflict like I'm I'm not
consciously trying to inflict pain I
honestly feel
until we I've been a better mom I've
been able to focus on the therapy like I
actually spent quote-unquote finish
therapy like to the point where my
therapist is like I don't know that I
need to see you every week so that's
honestly why I don't have her to talk to
right now about it let me let me walk
through a couple of of choices I think
we've got number one
you told her I'm I'm done I wish you the
best I'm going to pray for you to have
joy in your life but it won't be include
me or your grandkids that's number one
um so think again think of your boundary
you just you just put up a wall and
think of that wall that someone's just
throwing stuff over the wall that you
can throw that out that's fine you can't
come over the wall they can throw crap
over all day so that's number one
number two is you can
um respond
by basically opening the little crack
I'm thinking of like a medieval castle
and they just and there's a big thick
wooden door and they just move that
little bitty that little bitty thing at
the beginning you know in the door
that's like a little bitty box it's like
a little bit square and you all you can
see is just your eyes
and you can you could lean out and go
hey I got your note thank you so much
for sending that I wish you the best and
close it back
okay you can do that
if you know your mom I mean you know
your mom about anybody if you do that
that might be a wink to her
thank you so much that your apology
meant the world to me I'm really
grateful I wish you the best
that is I'm not we're not going back to
the old days what I sent you in that
email still stands but I did wanted to
say thank you like you can do that but
you know your mom for some people
that that would allow their mom some
peace to ride off into the sunset for
some that would be just the crack they
needed to you know bring a sewage truck
and just start pumping crap through that
door again right and then the third
thing is you go open the door and go
running out and hug your mom in the
field and like you know the The Notebook
music starts playing and all that kind
of stuff so you know better than anybody
what I would challenge you on is
um
don't roll this off on your therapist
they made a recommendation but they
didn't tell you what to do you had to
make the call yeah
um your friends have recommendations
cool
but at the end of the day you have to
live with this and so you and you also
know how your mom's going to respond so
I want you to feel empowered to do the
right thing for you and your family
yeah and um move forward from there
okay
so that's there's not a there's not a a
one-size-fits-all answer here
gotcha like that's why I haven't yet
because I actually received this letter
on Mother's Day I think but
with like the baby coming and last time
when I had a baby she was
so unhelpful and
it's honestly very damaging at the time
so it's like that feels like walking
back into our house that's still on fire
yeah why would I do that
well if you're going back in there to
rescue somebody Maybe
yeah but if you're going back in there
to try to make somebody feel better and
they won't get out of that burning house
too then yeah that's I mean
yeah yep that's it like I just escaped
and
and she's one of those people that will
sit in misery to try to bring you back
into it I think you've answered your own
question then
okay yeah well done well done Katie um
for everybody struggling with this kind
of situation like you've put up a
boundary whether it's with um an ex
whether it's with a parent whether it's
with a grandparent whether it's with
um whoever
number one expect that people are going
to try to test that boundary and see if
it's going to hold they're going to run
up against it they're going to throw
things over they're going to send notes
however they're going to try to find out
is this boundary gonna hold
number two expect other people to be
upset that that boundary exists because
that boundary disrupts not just the
relationship between you and the person
you're putting the boundary up but it it
affects other people siblings friend
groups uh Church groups everybody in
between
the third thing is there may come a
season when that boundary doesn't serve
you anymore and we're ready to move on
but for right now it's gonna stay or
whatever or I'm gonna give you a number
four I'm gonna give you an ultimatum
these things have to happen or this
boundary goes up great
conk we talked about on on a previous
show if you
um 80 year old man kiss my teenage
daughter after she's asked you and I've
asked you not to
then um we don't come around
if you're there we leave we leave
and if you drive down or fly down to my
house
and you knock on my door and you say I
am so sorry that I violated the Dignity
of
your family
but way more importantly I value the
Dignity of your bodily autonomy and the
autonomy of your daughter and I'm sorry
it will never happen again thank you for
calling me out on my abusive Behavior
um it will never happen again in fact
I'll be the chief advocate for you and
your family and nobody's gonna put your
hands on y'all
then maybe you say cool we can open this
door and give it a shot that's totally
up to you I just want people who put up
boundaries
boundaries are hard to put up if you put
up a boundary feel at peace you've done
the right thing
you're going to feel guilty you're going
to feel ashamed you're gonna feel those
things but if you feel the need to put
up a boundary put it up
put it up
and hold to it good for you Katie I'm
proud of you